how would you feel knowing some of the
steamiest on-screen kisses you've seen
were real because they weren't meant to
happen in the first place these actors
found themselves in spontaneous steamy
and occasionally hilarious moments with
kisses that were never written into the
script whether it was a crush a
direction or in the moment move these
smooches are unforgettable and made for
some great stories let's take a look at
these 20 kisses that were totally
improvised
i want you to watch this and i want you
to burn this into your brains in the
finale of season two max and lucas share
a sweet kiss at the snowball dance this
kiss was never written in and later in
an episode of beyond stranger things
actress sadie sink confessed that she
wasn't comfortable with the scene
earlier in the day she was told that
there would be a kiss and she protested
what no no that's not in the script
that's not happening the actress
unfortunately felt like she didn't have
a choice so she wound up doing the kiss
on camera
while filming jurassic world chris pratt
and bryce dallas howard share a kiss
after she saves him from a small
dinosaur and helps him up from the
ground
turns out this wasn't scripted and
director colin trevorrow had pulled
pratt aside right before they filmed the
scene to tell him to surprise his
co-star with a kiss and i was like
hollywood
the 2015 film the hunger games
mockingjay part 2 included a smooch
between woody harrelson and elizabeth
banks that harrelson initiated
however the kiss wasn't just for the
scene after the fact harrelson confessed
to having a crush on banks and explained
that he'd spontaneously decided to kiss
her the actor said she's such a pro you
know and went with it while filming
the movie brought a very unexpected kiss
between lawrence and adams during a
tense scene the kiss wasn't originally
meant to happen but adams thought it
would add something unique to the scene
so she brought the proposal to lawrence
before they filmed the actresses agreed
and now the two have their moment
captured on film forever you know it and
i know it these two actors didn't share
just one but multiple unplanned kisses
over the seven seasons of the series it
was max greenfield playing schmidt that
initiated all the unplanned smooches
with his co-star during the first season
as a result it became an ongoing joke
between greenfield and johnson both on
set and offset they definitely got a lot
of kisses in as johnson has said that
he's locked lips with greenfield more
than any girl he's ever dated
i felt like you needed that more than i
did
the always hilarious steve carell
surprised both viewers and his cast when
he planted a kiss on oscar nunez
it was episode one of season three that
corral decided to lovingly smooch nunes
character in front of everyone to make
up for some homophobic comments he'd
made the whole scene was actually
improvised by corel there were versions
of the scene that were filmed without
the kiss but we're glad they included
this take in the episode
episode 24 of season 14 of the medical
drama brought a spontaneous and silly
kiss to the screen ludington who plays
joe goofully kissed capshaw's character
arizona the kiss came between two pecks
to joe's fiancee alex it caught everyone
by surprise and ludington explained that
while doing the exciting and joyous
scene she thought who wouldn't want to
kiss arizona robbins
i was the biggest fan i'd watched since
the beginning while filming a romantic
scene on the beach the director of the
2010 film started telling cyrus and
hemsworth to try doing different things
for the scene like splashing and pushing
each other then she said they should
kiss and they did well your sister just
got kissed
dad that wasn't the last time they
locked lips since after that the actors
dated for eight years and were married
for another two
episode 17 of the fourth season was a
special musical episode tribute to the
cult classic hedwig and the angry inch
what's up riverdale are you trying to
tear me down
actor casey cott was singing a song from
the show that traditionally includes
kissing a random audience member while
filming the scene caught opted to do the
same and picked fellow actor kj app for
the surprise kiss
in a flirtatious scene from the second
episode of season seven there was a
surprise kiss between gemma whelan and
indira varma it seems like you don't
need a protector
whelan later said that it wasn't in the
script however while the two were acting
together it felt like they should do the
kiss the 2011 supernatural drama series
brought viewers a sweet and spontaneous
kiss on the cheek given to rhoden by
o'brien in the premiere of season six
turns out it was a great move because
fans were so excited by the idea of them
being together that it resulted in a
romantic storyline for the characters in
the series hey lydia
thank goodness because we are absolutely
team stydia
one of the most noteworthy scenes in a
room with a view was actually made up on
the spot the crew of the film was trying
to find a magical spot for the scene to
take place wanting cornflowers
originally they ended up having to
settle for a poppy field the actors were
given some loose guidelines juden you
stand there and then the romantic kiss
came along naturally how could it not in
an italian poppy field the writers of
the 2014 sci-fi film had a hard time
finding where a romantic moment could
happen between blunt and cruz's
characters so blunt went ahead and took
it into her own hands that's a challenge
after the writers gave up on trying to
write the kiss in blunt went ahead and
kissed cruz we think tom cruise was
probably pretty happy about the surprise
the two actors were reunited in this
film after not appearing on screen
together for nearly 35 years
look
one of the most tender and
heart-wrenching scenes of the film has a
kiss that was totally spontaneous it
came pretty easily since the two actors
had such a long history shortly after
filming fisher passed away we imagine
hamill was happy to have that special
moment with her
the 2003 film has a long kiss between
the co-stars after murray whispers in
johansen's ear in the final scene
everything from the whisper to the kiss
was made up on the spot by murray what
was whispered remained a secret for
years
while filming the graduation scene
garfield and stone shared a spontaneous
kiss the kiss was pretty in the moment
and natural since the two were dating at
the time garfield said that while they
were shooting the scene he figured his
character would kiss stone at that
moment and since they were locking lips
regularly he probably didn't give it
much more thought
can't keep me away
tommy davidson thought it would bring
some excitement to the film if he kissed
pinkett smith on set while filming one
of the scenes it wasn't the best
surprise because davidson didn't realize
that a kiss should be rehearsed and
agreed upon when he moved in to kiss his
co-star she pulled back and they didn't
end up fully kissing will smith was very
upset about the incident and nearly
fought davidson over the unexpected pass
so i was like all right let's go outside
let's talk and then jada was like no no
no
episode 5 of season 5 has a scene that
includes a kiss between jacks played by
hunnam and venus van damme a
transgendered prostitute played by
goggins the kiss wasn't scripted goggins
whispered to hanum just trust me before
shooting the scene and after they called
action goggins gave hunnum the tender
kiss
goodbye tag
the finale of season one brought a
surprise kiss between fellow teachers
will and emma i love you emma i finally
said it well the truth is it was only a
shock for one of them writer director
brad falchuk told morrison to surprise
mays with a smooch before they filmed
the scene making maze's reaction totally
authentic
if you were an actor would you ever
surprise a co-star with a kiss
let us know which of these actors you
would have liked to get a spontaneous
kiss from in the comments below if you
enjoyed exploring these hollywood
smooches give us a like and share the
video don't forget to hit subscribe to
keep up with all our content